a group of veterans at Prestige Assisted
Living honored during a ceremony today
among them a World War II vet who was
one of the few people to train with the
first Tuskegee Airmen as reporter Brian
will explains they were the first black
aviators in the U.S armed forces
honoring those who gave so much
including a 102 year old veteran who has
quite a story to tell Lester
chance
the United States
Army retired lieutenant colonel 102 year
old Lieutenant Colonel Lester mccance
stood to receive his honor he was one of
the first black Pilots to fly solo from
U.S to Korea the recall from the events
that I work with the people that I
served with make you feel very very
humble lieutenant colonel mccance was
joined by his great niece Leslie mccance
who worked as a civilian contractor in
the Middle East service runs in the
family and she is very proud to me it's
inspirational just to know that what
he's been through and if you just
listening to the stories like you know
what they had to overcome back then you
know even him having his rank it's more
as inspirational Lieutenant Colonel
mccance has received numerous Awards
including personalized notes from
President Obama but this ceremony was a
surprise they say it was a surprise and
then had this happened I didn't know
what was going on but the girls have
been pushing me one place to the other
and I might have known something was
wrong but what's his secret to a long
happy life he's a jokester even at 102.
he's seemingly happy to be here each
veteran today received a pin a
certificate and an American flag
reporting in Henderson Brian will eight
news now
now a veteran officer was at the event
to make sure the veterans had access to
the services they earned such as
disability compensation and pensions for
those who qualify for additional income
as for the lieutenant colonel he turns
103 this summer